are there comedians who only date
comedians well i remember natasha legero
only only dating i think and then she
married motion she was a very funny
comedian and i remember because i was
wondering if i should date a comedian
and i end up dating a comedian yeah and
she's like it's the best because they
understand beds and they understand
clubs and for me
and that person and i are still very
close but like that's that wasn't right
for me because two hit men dating each
other
it just yeah it becomes completely
normal that all you think about and all
you talk about is how to assassinate
like a brazilian
brother yeah those are good times who
books that right who books brazilian
dictator who books that yeah
crazy you're it is weird yeah yeah yeah
no i i what is weird about it you were
saying
it's weird because i i have felt that
way too
where
it is so funny to me that there are
people
i and maybe this is less of a thing now
but when i was younger it felt like more
of a thing where we would all sit around
and go like i mean
who else are you gonna date who else is
gonna get it yeah no one else is gonna
get it i'm like people in the army don't
say this yeah like people who have been
to war aren't like i no one's gonna
understand where i'm coming from
unless and it's like we're just doing
dick jokes like no one else can south
bend funny bone if you don't get those
four words i can't love you
you're right if you haven't been to cap
city i mean
what
how will there'll be a level we never
get to there are people in platoons
doing things that most people will never
do and they don't talk to us that way
no it's so stupid we are so stupid
we're so stupid but you get to a point
where you're like oh we're just like
enabling each other's insecurities and
workaholism well that's what i that's
what i ultimately thought it was you
yeah when you're dating another comedian
not all of them clearly i think natasha
and moshe are a wonderful couple but
when i did it it was like you won't get
in my way i'm like uh tom cruise in
collateral
and i'm like look i'm in a cab killing
seven people in los angeles in one night
can you be my jamie foxx
and they're like i have people to kill
too
i'm you know yeah i i have a thing too i
also have a thing i'm killing six people
doesn't mean you're better than me are
you gonna drive tomorrow
[Music]